le jury des professionnels les a
déplacés à la quatrième place mais le
public envoyer un message fort en leur
offrant la toute première
salle que françois merci de soutenir
l'ukraine cette victoire est pour tous
les ukrainiens gloire à l'ukraine pour
nous aujourd'hui toute victoire est très
importante
alors applaudissons la nôtre gloire à
l'ukraine
et il le promet l'an prochain son pays
accueillera l'eurovision je chante comme
si je devais mourir demain j'aime
comme si je devais mourir demain faut
tout faire comme si on devait mourir
demain car il n'est pas dit que demain
on meurt pas à accéder quand comme
poutine nous sommes arrivés aujourd'hui
à une décision importante qui inclut la
coopération entre le gouvernement et le
président nous espérons que le parlement
confirmera notre choix d'adhérer à
l'otan dans les prochains jours au moins
dix morts dans une tuerie aux états unis
à buffalo dans l'état de new york
l'auteur présumé de l'attaqué un
suprémaciste blanc a été arrêté sur
place et incarcéré le fbi privilégie le
caractère raciste de cette tuerie le
premier ministre jean castex devrait
présenter sa démission en début de
semaine et une femme pourrait être nommé
pour le remplacer la seule première
ministre française edith cresson lui
souhaite bon courage
il ya beaucoup de noms qui reviennent à
nos oreilles ces derniers jours pour
remplacer jean castex elisabeth bornes
l'actuel ministre du travail marisol
touraine
l'ancien ministre de la santé sous
françois hollande audrey azoulay la
directrice de l'unesco est ce que ça
veut dire que toutes les femmes sont non
excessive non violente je ne dirais pas
non plus tout parce que je j'ai beaucoup
de mal à enfermer les êtres humains dans
leur dans leur génétique de naissance
fils y en a une qui se détache un peu
plus ces dernières heures ces derniers
jours il s'agit de catherine vautrin
actuelle présidente du grand reims
ancien ministre sous raffarin souville
pas ancien député les républicains a
rejoint emmanuel macron je crois au mois
de février donc est ce qu'elle est prête
encore à faire un pas supplémentaire
c'est-à-dire appliquer une politique qui
serait totalement contraire à ce qu'elle
a défendu pendant des années c'est son
problème ça la regarde avec moi le
choisit le choix du premier ministre à
la limite peu m'importe c'est le
problème du président de la république
c'est pas mon problème à moi le
président de la république ne peut pas
ne pas nommer une femme cette fois ci
nommé un homme je crois qu on lui dirait
c'est à dire l'analyse parce que il
journée à tous les commentaires entend
tourner autant et du fait qu'il fallait
que ce soit une femme qui aurait
évidemment une déception très nette est
évidemment totalement injustifiable vous
vous dites que head premier ministre
d'emmanuel acron ça serait facile pour
vous non je crois pas parce que c'est un
personnage volontaire je me suis
moi-même mais il faudra s'en tenir à la
constitution puisque c'est elle qui
s'applique et la constitution prévoit
que c'est le premier ministre qui dirige
la politique de la nation par le
président de la république une seule
femme a tenu ce poste durant la
cinquième république c'est edith cresson
oui et des créations qui cet extrait
mais dans un entretien au journal du
dimanche souhaiter beaucoup de courage à
la future première ministre et
fustigeant au passage le le machisme de
la classe politique française vous le
voyez ce n'est pas le pays qui est
machiste c'est sa classe politique oui
c'est vrai que dans la classe politique
il reste encore beaucoup de matchs isme
sur lequel il faut lutter
avoir une femme à matignon pourquoi pas
mais c'est surtout pour quoi faire
quelle sera sa feuille de route quelles
seront ses actions quelle sera la
politique à mener en fait ce
qu'attendent les français c'est pas tant
de savoir si ce sera une femme ou un
homme qui m'ont fait le reproche de
vouloir quitter l'europe on a entendu
avec mélenchon c'est l'europe à la carte
etc c'est exactement ce qu'il vient de
dire que les traités doivent être vues
qui sont obsolescence c'est à dire que
ça ne marche pas ou qu'il vous a copié
mais en tout cas il est venu sur une
position de bon sens et le bon sens chez
moi la fable de jean luc mélenchon
opposant les milieux macron à cet arrêté
maintenant hein ça a duré quinze jours
ça fait rire tout le monde la réalité
c'est que jean luc mélenchon a fait
élire emmanuel macron